let's see what you're going to cover in
this course
so there are five sections in which this
course has been divided in
the fundamentals the basics attack
techniques
the industry tools and defending sqli
in fundamentals i'll cover the what when
where why and how of sql injections
and i'll show you the lab setup that you
will need for this course
the basics will cover the basics of sql
again it's not basic sql injection it's
basic of sql
and then types of sql injection after
that we'll move on to the attack
techniques where i'll show you various
adapt techniques that you can implement
in this world and it's completely
hands-on
finally i'll show you how to use
industry specific tools
to use sql injections and to leverage
them efficiently and effectively
and we'll wrap up this with the lecture
on defending sql injections where i'll
show you the best practices
that you should be following and again
i'm not a programmer so don't worry
i'll not show you the coding practices
i'll show you what the real stuff is
let me go ahead and quickly introduce
myself experience wise i worked with
multiple fortune 500 companies
and government bodies on highly complex
and confidential projects
saving them over 25 million dollars
every year
last year we saved over 72 million
dollars if we combine everything
i have authored multiple international
best-selling programs
as well as i am the author of the book
called penta secrets which is an
amazon's global bestseller
i have trained over 35 000 cso's who are
today
leading the world's infosec economy i
hold the ccso
lpt master ecsa ceh chfi
cei as some of my ec council credentials
i have been a former board member for
ces governance board
for india middle east and africa region
and kvm board members of ec council
in asia pacific region my core expertise
is in managing
double-blind penetration tests which are
budgeted at least hundred thousand
dollars or above
here's the disclaimer sagar bunsel sagar
pencil group of companies our partners
ad affiliates
youtube its partners and affiliates are
not responsible for any of the actions
you take
after completing this course or watching
this video
any numbers claimed within this video
are for reference purposes only any
trademarks used in this video are the
intellectual property of their
respective owners
and the video contains professional
penetration testing knowledge and
everything has been done in a controlled
simulated environment
what are sql injections and why do they
occur
it's an interesting question because sql
injection is one of the top 10
vulnerabilities as per or wasp
and it's been there for years and still
we see it
let me tell you a story before i get
started so this year in february we
bought this car
on my birthday now it's a mercedes-benz
c-class and there is no bench showroom
in my city
so we had to take the delivery from
another city however when we were taking
it out of showroom
there was a checkpoint on the checkpoint
there was a camera which scans the
number plate of the car
on the number plate it scans that number
and compares that number in the database
and if the car is involved in some kind
of fraud
or if there is some ticket pending or if
there is some criminal charges
it will not open however we just bought
this card five minutes ago
it doesn't even has a number plate that
was completely blank
now here i have two options i could even
wait there for a whole day
get a number plate maybe a temporary one
and then pass through the checkpoint
or what i did is i wrote the special
characters which is
s-a-g-a-r single quote or
one equals one now this is a special
query
when you put this in any database it
will always return true and
the checkpoint compared this thing in
the database and checkpoint said
yeah allow this color and it just opened
and i took my curve
and that's how i passed that checkpoint
by putting in a scale injection
now let me explain how the statement
bypasses any checkpoint
you see think about a login page how
does a login page looks like
there is a username there is a password
and there is a login button
right at the front end but think about
the back end
in the back end there is a lot of code
as you can see on your screen right now
you don't need to learn coding but try
to focus on that red
part of the code that is the code which
is responsible
to check if your password and username
is true or not
let me make it more easier so this is
the simplified version of the core
in this code it's asking select start
from login where username equals
something password equals something
so there is the field username there is
the field password
in a login form you fill these fields
and it goes to the database and it
checks
hey is there any user in the login table
which has the username of sagar
and password as pencil if there is it
will return a result if there is not it
will not return result
so the parameter here we can choose any
of these let's say password
this is the expected input password
equals x y z
but a hacker like me will not give x y z
i will give x single chord y z
now do you see what just happened here
that x
was supposed to be closing with xyz
and then that single quote however i
just added a single quote and now i have
two statements
password equals x and then there is
another statement which is y
z and single court now once i am able to
do that
i can write an exploit like select star
from login where username equals sagar
and password equal x or
one equals one so the system will check
okay is there any user which is sagger
and is the password x
or just check if 1 is equal to 1 which
is always true that is a tautology
1 is always equal to 1 which means that
the result will be true and
it will return a true statement and i
will be able to log in
this is the reason sql injection occurs
when you are able
to control the database put some data
and manipulate it according to your wish
that's a skill injection becomes so
deadly
of course we'll be talking about how to
make these queries how to write this
code in later lectures
but this is the concept that is how sql
injection works
this is the reason of sql injections to
exist when user is able to give
certain data and control the database
with that data
that is where sql injection comes into
the picture
in this lecture we will go ahead and
configure our lab
which will be using for this course for
that i want to download
xampp for windows if you're using linux
then download them for linux
or if you're using os x then use xampp
for osx
the php version which i would recommend
should be 7.2.33
just go ahead download this and install
it's a simple next next next install so
i'll not show that right now
once you have installed this just go
ahead and search for xampp control panel
that is the software which you will use
to control this
now here you have apache which is your
web server
in mysql which will be using as a
database
so go ahead and start both of these
processes
once you're done with that you can close
this window you don't need it
and now go to your installation folder
of sam
in my case that's installed in c drive
here you'll find mysql
in mysql you have something called bin
and here you have all the files for
mysql
open the command prompt or a terminal
window in this location
and type mysql
dash u space root we want to log in as
root
and there is no password by default once
you do that you will be able to log into
the database
now here you have to create a database
so say create
database and give it a name
the name should be spva once you do that
it should say
ok query one row affected
you can show databases query to see if
the database exists
or not once this is done you can close
the terminal
and now you need the web application you
can download this web application
from my website sagrobinso.com
here you can go to sbva which is sagar
princess vulnerable application
and you can click on download now to
download this application
this is the spva folder let's open it
copy everything again go to your xampp
installation folder
this time find a folder called httpdocs
this one
by default if there are some files in
this folder delete everything
that's all good if this folder is empty
just go ahead and paste this
it's the same thing you delete it make
it empty and paste
all the files which you downloaded from
my website
now once this is done you just need to
go ahead and open in your browser
localhost slash setup.php
once you do that the application will be
ready to install
you don't have to do any other
configuration you can go ahead click on
this login page
and try to exploit this login page that
is how
you set up this environment however
in this course i will also be using an
online application
called test php once you search test php
on google
it'll say home of acunetix r
this website is owned by a kinetics
company and it's a testing website as
you can see
testphp.worldweb.com on this website
there is browse categories in that there
is paintings
this sometimes gives you an error
because someone else in some other
country is trying to hack this website
as this is made for hacking that's all
good just refresh the website
it will load eventually and this is the
page which we will be exploiting in the
course
so this page and sbba application
both of the things that makes up our lab
the basics of mysql it's really
important for you to understand
basics of writing sql queries
of course i will not be teaching you all
the sql language in one shot
and of course it's not an advanced sql
class but you need to know
very basic language so that you can use
them to understand the sql injection
queries
for that i need you to log into your
mysql console
now the first command is show databases
which will give you all the databases
that you have
next event is create databases
and you can create any database in this
case i'm creating a database called
x and you see query one row effector
if you run the show database again you
will see you got a new database
next command is to select the database
so you say use and the database name
which is use x
now we are in the x which is determined
by this
column here now let's see if there is
any table in this
show tables for that however it's an
empty set
because there is no table let's create
and table them
so i'm going to create a table called
users now the reason i have these braces
here
is because i will be putting what kind
of data will be stored in this users
the data will be first of all name now
the name is the name of the column
okay that's the name of the column where
the data will be stored
but what type of data there are certain
types in sql
and it depends on the product that
you're using in my case i'm using mario
db implementation of sql
so the type which i have to use is
wirecare
and in wirecare i have to tell it how
many characters the name can be
let's go 100 characters so someone can
type a name
which will be stored in the name which
will be of varchar
type which is characters and that'll be
100 characters
let's press enter and you see query okay
zero rows affected
let me show you the tables now you can
see we got a table called users
if i select everything from users by
using the select query
where star means everything so select
everything
that's there in the user show me
everything that's there in the users
you will see it says empty set however
i can go ahead and add something here by
putting
insert into values
so i can use insert into table name
which is users
i can insert into this users table
values and i need to give the values
since i only have one column which is
name i'll give the values here if i'm
using name i have to use double cards
and i can give a name like sagger
i can press enter and you see one row
affected
if i do select star you will see there
is a column name
and there is a value which is in server
similarly i can add more users by using
the same query
and saying second user as alice
and third user as bob and if we try to
see the users
and you can see there are three records
which are these which are in the column
of name
which are in the table of users which
are in the database called x
i can delete some stuff let's say the
whole database by saying
drop database x you can do the same for
tables as well
drop table and the table name as soon as
i do
drop database x you can see it says none
here
and there is no database now so if i
just show you the databases
you can see we don't have x anymore
that's how you delete the database
now there are three functions that i
want to explain the function of user
so i can say select user
you can see it gives us the output of
user
running on the server so we are running
this as root
there is another function called version
which is going to give us the version
number of the database
and there is another function called
database
which will throw us null because we are
not using any database
however if an application is using a
database like
uses pva now my application is using
sbba database
if i do select database you will see
that it gives the database as the result
so these three functions can be really
helpful while gathering data
in sql injections this is the core basic
that you need to understand
there are many things like ore and where
order by group by but this is not an sql
class
though i will be explaining all of these
things in the course whenever i can
but you can always use google as your
friend
the classic injection bypass well the
classic injection bypass can occur at
any place for this example i will be
using an application that i developed
it's called
spva sagger benzel's one rebel
application so you can go to this login
page and this is the place where i'll
show you how to do a classic injection
bypass
because this is the easiest to
understand
now it's a simple login page if i do
anything like admin admin which is a
wrong
username and password it will not throw
any error and not even say that the
username is wrong or the password is
wrong
it's completely disabled with the errors
however
if i use a correct username which is
sagger
and if i use a correct password which is
bunsel
i'll go ahead and log me in and you can
see
now i can log out and this is the place
where i'll try
to do a classic ejection bypass first of
all we need to understand how the code
of this application is working to make
it easy for you let me show you the
command line
and i'm going to show you the tables
here
there are two tables we will use login
table
i can see in the login table there are
just three entries id
username password id is one username is
sagar password is pencil
now what do you think the backend of
that website is using
as php the query might be
select start from login where username
equals
sagar and password equals pencil
let me show you how
so this might be the query that the
website is using select start from login
your username equals sagar
now you control this sagger
by putting it in the website over here
in username field
and you also control this bundle by
putting it
again in this field which is password
field
the ability to be able to control these
fields
which are being directly used as an
input in an sql query
is very dangerous and that is where you
can do a classic injection bypass
let's look at it carefully since i am
the one who controls what i will put in
the sagar
can i not go ahead and put s
a g in a double cards space
now do you see what just happened i just
created
sag as the variable and i have got the
ability to write some code here and this
all is an additional thing it was not
supposed to exist
right this was never supposed to exist
it was supposed to be
and here well i just break this
double quotes by putting a double quotes
and that's where the classic injection
bypass works
so instead of this thing i may put
sagger
and a double quotes to break and then or
one equals one which is basically
that check if username is sagar
or one equals one that is a classic
injection bypass
however there is a small problem in this
this cork is never supposed to be here
and this code is never supposed to be
here
in such a case we may go ahead and
utilize this court
by putting one code here one here
and one here and similarly we may use it
by putting it one here one here
and one here now this is a perfect
sql statement select start from login
where username equals sagger or
one equals one and password equals
bunsel or
one equals one so basically i can go
ahead and press enter
and this will work however even if i
give it a wrong username and password
like admin this time
this will still work because the
statement of
where clause is being nullified by the
statement of or clause in both of the
cases
this password and this username doesn't
matters until
1 is equal to 1 and this will always be
equal to 1 because this is a tautology
so that is how you do an sql injection
bypass
there are many other ways to do that
maybe you cannot put these
double quotes in certain situations
then how do you do that so for an
example if you're breaking it from here
and you're typing or one equals one then
you may want to go ahead and remove the
whole part from here
by commenting it out comments in sql
depends on the product
in mysql you can use a hash sign
or a minus minus sign or minus minus
space minus sign
or a slash asterisk sign
there are many ways to comments and some
will work some will not work
so you have to try all of them let's try
with hash
as soon as i press hash all of the
preceding code will be marked as a
comment
so my query is select start from login
where username equals sagar
or one equals one that's it everything
else is being ignored
now let me try to press enter and let's
see this works
and here you go it's asking you for a
semicolon because
the semicolon is getting ignored so
there should be a semicolon
before this comment sign i'm going to
press this
i'll work however a good query will be
putting a semicolon over here before
this sql sign and i see
it works perfectly so i can go ahead and
try
another type of comment like minus minus
that works as well i may try minus minus
space minus in certain cases minus minus
doesn't works
so minus minus space minus may work
however here you may say that you know
what
this is just getting commented out so it
doesn't matter whatever i press here
and you know i can even write this thing
it will all get commented out
however as i said in certain cases minus
minus doesn't works
minus minus space minus vertex so
you may want to keep that in mind it
works
i may want to try with a with a slash
asterisk this also works
and here you can see suddenly something
has
changed in my database and it doesn't
looks correct
so it is asking me for a star
slash you know to close the comment it's
a multi-line comment
you can comment multiple lines by
writing slash asterisk
and then asterisk slash to close the
comment
and it'll keep asking me for it until i
close it now i am back in my database
console
so we will not close it because if we
close it then
this statement will not get commented
out hence in certain cases we just keep
it open and the system automatically
ignores this part sometimes
this one is risky but works now that you
know how it's working
let's go ahead and try to bypass the
website itself
so i will put a username it double
quotes
or one equals one and then a hash
sign i will copy the same thing and put
it in password
though it doesn't matter so we're just
commenting out the rest of the thing
oh we just forgot a semicolon here
now let's try the login well that didn't
work
what just happened let me tell you one
thing
in certain cases this double quotes can
be replaced by
single quotes it completely depends on
what the developer has decided to use
so in this case
the website is not using a double quote
the website is using a single code
which is a common practice so the
website is using the single quotes
instead of double
hence to break out from it i need to put
a single quote
here not a double quote and then i can
press or one equals one
so in the website i will put a single
code here
not a double and now i can press login
and you can see i was able to log in
without putting any password
that is how a classic injection bypass
works
types of sql injection there are
multiple types of sql injections which
you should be aware of
because depending upon the target and
the situation you may have to switch
between one type and another
there are two major categories of
vascular injections first one is in-band
sql injection
and second is inferential scale
injection
imbalance conjunction occurs when you
are able to get
the response from the website it can be
some data
or it can be some error so think about a
database
a database containing a lot of paintings
you are able to get those paintings
depending upon your searches
you're searching for painting which has
an id of one
which has an id of two which has an id
of three or you're searching that on the
basis of price
any painting which is costing less than
five thousand dollars
any painting which is worth more than
twenty thousand dollars
depending upon this you'll be getting
some data from the database
those are data based sql injections
there you can use a technique
called union based sql injection
technique where you will use the union
command
of sql i know it's being a little
confusing don't worry
i'll be explaining what is union and how
to do that
in a whole separate lecture but just
understand when you are able to get data
from the application
you will most probably go with the union
based technique
the second one is error-based injection
in certain website you might have seen
that when you do a search or you click
on a button
it sometimes throws an error that error
is coming because there is some problem
in the database
and when we are able to take advantage
of the errors to inject our sql
that is where we use the error based
injection techniques
again i'll have a separate lecture on
this so till now you understood that
there are two categories
in-band sql injections and inferential
skill injections
in in-band you have the database
technique called union based injection
and the error-based technique called
error-based injection
now coming on the inferential injection
in certain cases you will not get the
error
neither the data there you have to
analyze the behavior of the application
either you are logging in or you are not
logging in
it's not throwing any error that
password is wrong username is wrong it's
not giving you an error
it's just letting you log in or you're
not able to log in
that's where you analyze the behavior am
i able to log in
that is a true statement is it not
allowing me to log in that is a false
statement
this true and false is called as boolean
injection technique
similarly you can observe the time taken
by the server
when you request a page it may take five
seconds
to open that whole page in certain cases
it may take 20 seconds to open the same
page
that is where you can analyze the time
taken by the server
to process some requests and that is
known as the time
based injection techniques so as a recap
in inferential we do not rely on data or
errors
rather than the behavior of the
application either we will get
true or false behavior which will lead
to the boolean injection technique
or we'll get some time differentiations
which will lead to time-based injection
techniques
well there even exists a third type of
technique
which is called as out-of-band
injections
the reason i'm not discussing this and
we will not even be covering this in the
course
is that out of band is a very rare
situation
it is not even applicable in every sql
product for an example
this normally is found on databases
which are from a brand called oracle
there is a special package in that
called utl underscore http
with which we can get the response in
our
netcat listener so you can set up a
netcat listener and you can get response
of your queries in your listener
it's highly rare situation and will not
fit the scope of this course
that's the reason we will ignore out of
the ban but in a nutshell
out of bad skill injections are the
injections which do not occur on the
application
rather in the background they occur
somewhere else
like a netcat listener being hosted by
you
so these are the three categories of sql
injections and we will be covering the
first two
in the following lectures in detail
union based sql injection well a union
based sql injection occurs
when we are able to use the union
operator to combine the output of two
select statements
as you can see in the following screen
this first
image which has some lot of some text
and has an author name with a link and
actually an image is the result of the
website's default code
however i was able to create a virtual
image
which you can see right here which
doesn't exist which has
a name as the database user
instead of the description it has the
database
itself and instead of the painter name
it has
the version information of the database
so i was able to create a virtual row
and extract data to that seems
complicated right
let me make it easy for you
i have two tables in this database first
one is
login
if we see the login table there are
three columns id
username password ids one username is
sagar
password is sponsor just wondercore
now if i use union operator and i try to
combine
one two three i will be able to combine
another
row which has the value one two three
let me show you how that works
as you can see i just typed select star
from login
union select one two three and there is
certainly
another row which has the value one two
three
this will only work when you are giving
the exact number of
columns if i try to give only one and
two
it'll throw an error because the third
column will not have
a value to put in
as you can see when i try to give only
select 1 and 2
it says the select statement have a
different number of columns
so it should always be the same number
of columns which are putting here
now i can go ahead and extract data
instead of three i can put
version and i'll throw up the version
number
instead of one i can put username i'll
throw
the user instead of one i can put the
database
i'll throw the database name seems easy
right
so i can just copy this thing
and take it to this website and run it
and it will work
will it well no it won't it'll throw an
error let me show you what
you can see it says the select statement
has different number of columns
you cannot expect them using three
number of columns right
so they might be using four columns or
five columns or six columns
there are two ways to find columns first
is brute forcing
where you can try select one
that doesn't works then you can try
select one and two
that also doesn't work and you can then
try select one two three
that will also not work but this method
may take a lot of time hence we can use
an efficient method
which is order by clause
instead of putting select statement i
can put order by
and i can say order by 20
and it says unknown column 20 in order
clause
this means that the number of column is
less than 20.
if i try 10 now
it works which means the number of
columns is either 10 or more than 10.
so now i know they are in the range of
10 to 20. i can use a middle range which
is 15
and that throws an error so unknown
column 15 it means
our columns are in between the range of
10 and 15.
now i can put 13. it still throws an
error which means our number of columns
is either 10
11 or 12. i can put 11
that works so either 11 or 12.
well 12 throws another which means the
number of columns in this application
are 11 which gives us the output
so i can say now select 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11.
now you can see it creates a virtual
table
but point to understand here is not
every column
is accessible i can see 7 here
i can see 2 here i can see 9 here
so i can extract information through
column number 7
through column number 2 and through
column number 9.
these are three columns where i'm
getting the information
hence i can put my database
let's say in column number two
in column number seven i can put the
user
and in column number nine i can put
diversion
and you can see we were successfully
able to find the username
the database name and the version can we
take it forward
of course you can find any information
that you like
can you find other database yes it
depends on
how deep you understand sql language
so in order to find all the databases
there is a special table
called information schemas kimata
you can find that using this
there is a column called schema name in
a table
called schemata in a database called
information schema
as you can see here the first database
is always information schema
which contains this table schemata which
has a table
column called schema name which has all
of these entries
so if you query schema name from
information schema dot
it'll show you all the databases can i
take this thing
from here and can i put it
on the website
and now you can see we got first
database information schema
second database acquired and there are
no other entries which means
this specific website only has two
databases
information schema and acquired
i can go on and on with multiple
examples just to give you one more
example
on how to find the table names
so the query for that will be
select table name from information
schema.tables
where table schema equals x where x is
the database
which you want to find in this case i
found the x
where there is just one table called
users
can i take the same thing and put it on
the website of course
as you can see i just found the table
names the query i used was
table name from information schema.table
where table schema equals acquired
because i wanted to find the tables in
the database
called acquired and the table names are
artists cards k tech
feature guest book and so on
there is an interesting function that
you can use here which is
group concat
now when you use this function called
group can cad
and in that i am asking for table name
you can see it doesn't gives me a lot of
results
it just groups all of them together over
here
painted by artists cats catac feature
guest book pictures
products users so everything in one line
super clean stuff and that's how you do
union-based sql injections
error-based sql injection well an
error-based sql injection occurs when
you are able to trigger
certain bug in the product which leads
to some errors
and you have the ability to control
those errors to extract data
in the following screen you can see that
i was able to create an error
which is about a duplicate entry in the
group
key but in this error you can see i was
also able to extract
the version number of the database
the database name and the user of the
database
this is what an error based skill
injection is all about
now as i just said this depends on the
product and a bug
in that product you can see that this
version is
5.1.7
let me show you a page here you can see
5.7
so i'm using a much older version on
that website however
this bug id 82544
this bug is valid in all the latest
versions in 2020 as well
it was published in 2016 but even after
four years this has not been patched
and looking at the history i don't think
so it's going to be patched soon
so the bug is about a duplicate entry in
the group
key while doing a group by clause
if you go ahead and scroll down you will
see that you can create this error
by selecting something counting it
concatenating the stuff
with rand function concatenating with
floor function
from certain table and grouping it by
some value
sounds complicated right don't worry
i'll break all of this for you
so i'm going to show you all of this in
my test environment
i do have the following databases i will
use x for this specific test
there is just one table in this database
called users
in this specific table there is one
column called name
and there are three rows sagar alice
paul
now this error occurs when we are able
to associate
a random pattern for that the first step
is to associate a random value for each
of the results
to do that we use the rand function
as you can see when i select this column
which is name
it returns three rows but i also
selected a random function
which is creating three random values in
front of these
since it is a random function anytime i
create this again and again
it will create all new values you can
see
when i type this again all the values
have changed
if i type it once more all the values
have changed again
these values are completely generated
random and they will range
from 0 to 1. the next step to trigger
this bug is to control the output of the
random function
but i just told you it's completely
random you can use a seed value
here i will put a seed value like zero
now once i put a seed value the result
will always be same
this is what comes when i run it once
this is what comes when i run it twice
this is what comes when i write thrice
you can see all the times it's
generating
the same three values now the next step
is to
create a duplicate entry but my question
is
do you think this number has any
probability
to come on this place or on this place
these are billions of combinations so
the probability of this
is almost impossible for that
we will use a rounding function let me
tell you how that works
so in the following example i just added
a round function
on top of our rand function hence it is
rounding the values
to the closest zero or one and now there
is a hundred percent probability
that our value will repeat and there
will be a duplicate
entry since it will always be 0 1 1.
it doesn't matter how many times i try
this it will always
be 0 1 1.
you can see it never changes now that we
are able to generate
random values which are still controlled
by us
and we know that is going to create 0 1
1 and this one is a duplicate entry of
the above one
we can use the group by clause
now you can see when i use group by and
around rand
the results are not three but rather two
because this bob is also having the
value of 1
and alice is also having the value of 1
hence they have been grouped together
finally to trigger the bug we just need
to put
having min 0
and you can see duplicate entry 1 for
the key group key
that's the bug another approach which
the official guide says instead of
putting having min
you can put count so the count will come
here
and if i remove the having thing
i will still trigger the bug because bug
is coming from count
now this may sounds interesting that
this count is able to create the bug
but it's almost useless when using
error-based injections
the reason is that most of the times
this select
something from something statement is
locked
and we can only modify this part
just to give you an example it may be
select name
from users where name equals sagger
and then we can modify the group by
round function
you can see this is a standard database
query
select name from users where name equals
and we put this name in some search box
the problem of this is it is always
going to give you one result
however we need at least three results
for this bug to trigger
hence we can put or one equal one
to nullify this where statement so
think about it select name from users
where name equals sagar
or one equal one which is always true
hence it will select
all the names giving the whole table
as you can see it dumps the whole table
so now we can put our group by rand
having min equals zero
and this triggers the bug and this is
the final
output which we want as our payload
so i can copy this
i can go on this website
and you can see it normally takes a
parameter called cat
when it gives a parameter called cad it
comes up with all these images
if i give a parameter of cat equals 2
you can see it comes up with only one
result
so let me try to bypass this one cat
equals 2
since we already have or 1 equal 1 this
will bypass the situation of cat and
it'll give us all the rows in the table
and we'll group them by rand function
having min equal zero
i'll put a comment here to ignore the
other stuff
and you can see we get the error
duplicate entry one
key group key this one
is the result of our duplicate entry and
it's the result of our rand function
which is over here so can we use it to
extract data
of course let me show you that how we
can do it
now you can see what i just did is i did
a select name
round rand and then i did a concat
version
round ran so the output of round round
is 0 1 1
which you can see over here 0 1 1
and i concatenated this with the version
of the
application hence you can see since the
origin is constant
and round rand is changing we still have
a perfect duplicate copy of two and
three
these are perfect duplicates because
the version is constant and this part is
changing
hence in the same way we can concatenate
whatever we want and we can extract data
a good example here will be
you can see we got the database version
then we got x which is the database name
as you can see over here
then we got a root at the left local
host which is the user
we can even put spaces in between
and this will just make it easier for us
to identify that this is one thing
this is second and this is third and
this is finally the rand
so i can just take this whole
concatenation string here
and put it instead of this round run
function
and we got the version number
the database name
and the user at direct localhost
that is how error based sql injection
works and this is how we exfiltrate data
through error-based sql injections
boolean
based sql injection well a boolean
is a situation of zero or one which is
false or true there will be many cases
where you will find these kind of
situations it can be a simple
login page if your password is correct
you will log in
if it's wrong you will not so it's 1
or 0 or 0 or 1.
in this specific example you can see
if i try this specific command which is
cat equals to and
database equals acquired
so i am putting a condition here this
application
may be taking select star from something
where cath equals 2
which should give me this image what i'm
saying
and database is equal to acquired
so i'm giving it a database name if my
database name is correct
this application will show me the result
as you can see over here
however if i change this aqua to account
1
which is not the database name it will
not show me the result
as you can see this is where the boolean
injection
can be used to get data now
how do you get data out of it you can
put a lot of conditions here
and you can use patterns like like
pattern
length pattern substring
let me show you with examples here
i have this table called login
this table has an entry which is id1
username sagar
and password bunsel now a standard query
will be
select start from login where
id equals 1 and this will throw
the table if we say id equals 2
which doesn't exist in the database
it'll say empty set
which means it will not show me anything
so
instead of putting id 2 i can say id1
and i know that the statement is true
and i can say
and database
equal sbba which is the name of this
specific database
and since the statement is true you can
see we get the result
i can get the result even if the
statement of first
parameter is wrong
if it is where id equals 2 i can use the
command
or instead of putting and so select star
from login where id equals to
or database equals spva now
database is equal to spva for every
single of them
hence it shows us the same table so if
the statement is false you can use
or to get the data if the statement is
true you can use and to get the data
but the question is how do you get the
data how do you know that the database
name is sbva it's pretty simple
you can use the length function to find
the length first of all
so i can say select star from login
where id equals to or
length of the database is equal to one
and it says empty set
i can try two it again says empty set
i can try three it against his empty set
but when i try four
it gives me the result this tells me
that the length of the database is 4.
now we have to see what is the first
character
in this length for that we can use
substring
we can say select star from login with
id equals to
or substring of the database function
check the first character and only check
one character
and see if it is a however if we are
checking one character and if you are
checking the first character
it is not a it is s because the database
name is sbba
if i check s here you can see
we get the result so you can brute force
from a to z
by putting this kind of pattern
also you can check for the second
character by replacing the first one
this will not give me any result but if
i change this s to b
this time it gives me the result so the
first character
is s and the second character is p
similarly i can try for the third
character
which is v and i can try for the fourth
character
which will give me a result on a i can
even try combinations so instead of just
one character i can try two characters
at the same time
i'm going to try two characters starting
from first which is
s and b you can see it gives me the
result
i can try from second character two
characters which should be b
and a in sbva so b
and a if i try s b it won't give me the
result but if i try b and a
i'll give me the result well that
doesn't works
because it is not ba it is bv
and you can see sbva
i can try the whole database itself
by putting one and four which means
start from first character and
select four characters in the string
which is sbva
and that gives me the output i can even
use the like function here
to speed up the process
you can see in this command i'm using
select stuff on login where id equals 2
or
database like percent a percent
now what this percent means it's a wild
card
it means check if there is a
in the database name it can be at any
place
so any places before it any places after
it
you're just checking that i can say
check a b
that certainly isn't works but if i
check
v a that gives me the output
because s b v a are the last terms
i can remove the first percentage if i
need to
we will make it va but we will not get
any result
because we are saying see if the
database is like
va and then something which is wrong
because
the database is like sbva not va
something it's not v a n v a b
it's sbba instead i can do is i can
replace the last percentage and i can
say
check if database is like something
which ends with va
and this gives me the result
and that is how you can use the like
function to find stuff
i can even say s underscore
va which means i don't know what will be
there in between this
but there is just one character which
should give me
the result or i can just put a
percentage when i don't know the number
of characters which should again give me
the result
it's all about pattern matching let's
try to do the same thing on the website
so cath equals 2 and because we know
that cat
statement is true
the length of the database as 1 which is
not true and we don't get any
output length of database has two
doesn't works length has four
doesn't work length has six
certainly works because the database
name is acquired
a c u a r t which is six characters
and in this way you can go ahead and try
a lot of combinations
and try to extract data bit by bit using
boolean based sql injections
time-based sql injections well there
will be certain cases
where you will not be able to see any
output on the screen
it will be the screen which is same in
case of a valid statement
or an invalid statement in certain cases
instead of looking at the output
we can look at the time which the server
takes to process the request
or to send the response in the following
case i am trying to ask the server
that check if the database name is
acquired
if it is then sleep for 10 seconds
so if i press enter i don't get anything
on my screen but you can see the server
is taking 10 seconds
to give me the response it's sleeping
right now
and after 10 seconds it'll send some
response to me
which is again the same page so on my
response
nothing changes but it took complete 10
seconds
to show me the page instead if i just
put some random name here
it'll not take more than two seconds to
give me the response
that is where i can justify if the
statement is true or false
just by looking at how much time the
server is taking to give me the result
just to make it simpler for you i'm
going to show you a few examples
there is a table called users
and you can see in this table there are
three users sagar
alice and bob however let us assume that
we do not have the ability to play with
these users
every time the output is just these
three users
what can we do in such case we can use
sleep statement
by combining it with and select start
from users
and if and here you will put your sleep
statements
however please note this depends on
product to product
in case of this database which is a
mariadb implementation of mysql
the function works in condition
comma true comma false
which means you put your condition if
the condition is true
then this will happen if the condition
is false that this will happen
so if the condition is false sleep for
five seconds if the condition is true
sleep for two seconds and the condition
is
database equals a
if i try to run this it throws an error
and the error occurs because there is no
logical condition in this
you see to use time based injections you
need a logical condition
like where which you cannot control
so if the application instead of this is
using
where name
equals sagger
now the application is checking for a
logic select star from users very name
equals sagar
this is something which the application
is checking it's a logic condition
and then we are putting and also check
if database equals a
then sleep for 2 seconds or 5 seconds
this will work and you can see the
database is sleeping
but how much 2 or 5. you can see
it slept for 5 seconds which means
database name is not
a because it is x
so can i show you with the x of course
when i do it with the correct database
name it sleeps only for 2.002 seconds
two seconds because of the sleep
function zero zero two seconds to
process the request
again five seconds because of the sleep
function 0.009 seconds
to process the request similarly we can
use different patterns
like length
and now we are comparing if the length
of the database is
1 or not and in this case the length is
1.
if we see if the length is true or not
it'll say
no because it'll sleep for five seconds
giving me
the confirmation that the length is not
equal to two
i can even use a greater than sign here
so if length is greater than two then
sleep for two seconds
if not then slip for five seconds as you
can see
length is not greater than two it is
less than two
so i can say length is less than 2
and this will sleep only for 2 seconds
as you can see
so by such techniques you can analyze
the time of the database
and conclude if a situation is true or
false
i can even do length calculation here
so in this following example i am
checking if the length of the database
equals 5 then sleep for 5 seconds
otherwise sleep for 10 seconds
1 2 and it throws an error
let's see what the error is length okay
did we did some mistake
yes we forgot to close the lens function
so let's close it and let's try now 1
2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13
14 and maybe i'm counting too fast and
it just comes up with the result
and you know i can conclude that that
was definitely not five seconds
however if i try it with a number of six
which is actually the length a c
u a r t one
two three four
five so do we get the output yes we get
the output right
that is kind of how it works let me go
ahead and start a stopwatch instead
this should be easy
so i'm going to say
and do we get the result here
here we go we got the result in almost
four seconds but still
because i started it and it took one
second to you know come from browser to
stopwatch
it took one second over there if i do a
wrong statement
like five
and if i reset that
and if i press enter
then let's see
we got the output in 11.51 seconds
and assume it was taking somewhere 12
seconds because
i came from the browser to here this was
one more second
so roughly 12 seconds instead of 10 so
that is the processing time it is taking
but it is definitely clear that if the
request is true
it comes somewhere around five if the
request is wrong it comes somewhere
around 10
because i am giving that in my
assumptions
right that is how you get to know if it
is true or if it is false
and just like you use the length
function you can use the substring
function to calculate
the name of the database or to get any
kind of information from this database
it all depends on how well you
understand sql
but that is how the time-based sql
injections work
using semi-automated tools for sql
injection
well there will be certain situations
which will be humanly impossible for you
to test thousands and thousands of
payloads with
think about a login page if you're
bypassing a login page
and they have used certain filters it
will not be easy for you to try
all the possible combinations that is
where
semi-automated tools come into the
picture again
remember these are just semi-automated
they are not fully automated
you still need to understand why a skill
injection occurs
where do they occur how do they occur
and what is the reasoning behind
everything
and accordingly you can use them to
automate the heavy lifting
one of the tools which i personally like
is called burp suite
there are alternatives like os zap
however
burp swede is a good and reputed tool
you can download it from portswigger.net
just download the community edition and
install it it's available for all the
operating systems
it's a simple next next next install so
i will not cover that part
in community edition you cannot save the
data so you always have to start a
temporary project
that's fine with us
you can start with the default of verbs
that's also okay
just started and now verb has started
now there are many ways to use it
everyone has a preference
however in these new versions they have
started to make a built-in browser
if you go to this proxy you will see
there's a browser
here open browser
this is a chromanium browser and it's a
specially configured one
because it works with burp suite out of
the box
now here just make sure you do turn off
this intercept
because you can see it automatically
starts capturing a lot of requests
and we don't really need this just turn
this off
now go to your browser and open whatever
you want to open
so i'll open my target which is
localhost
and here i'll go to login
and here i'll put certain username and
password like
sagar as username and mypass as
password nicely it doesn't really works
of course the password was wrong so we
were not able to log in
that is fine we can go to burp and if
you go to http history
you will see all the requests that have
passed through burp
using this specific browser it may be
hard to find that request in these much
requests
so you can go to the target tab and it's
the graphical tree view
we are using a localhost and we are
using
login.php it is interesting
that this is not the right request
however there is one more login.php
which has certain percent 20 in that
but this is the right request you can
see username equals sagar password equal
mypass
this is what i typed so this is our
request
again there are two requests login.php
login.php
20 something that is fine with us
we can send this request to repeater
now you can see the repeater highlights
and now you can do whatever you want
with this request and
send it from here and the response will
come over in this window
so first of all let me try instead of my
pass
let me try the right password
which is bunzo let's try to send it
now let's click on render to see how it
works in the browser
and we were able to log in as you can
see login
if i use a wrong password
we're still able to log in which is
interesting the reason behind that is
because this website uses cookies once
you're logged in
the next request which you send doesn't
matter is because you have never pressed
this logout button
so instead of pressing the logout button
which is practically not possible
since it's just the response i can go
ahead and remove this cookie at all
once there is no cookie the website
doesn't recognize me that i am logged in
or not
it just processes the request let's try
again
now i can see i'm not logged in if i
type the right password
if i press send i am logged in
if i again type the wrong password
i am not logged in though the request is
working fine
however i would suggest that you remove
these additional characters from it
it doesn't really matters and it won't
affect your testing
but the file name is login.php not
login.php and these characters
so due to some processing it certainly
picks up these characters in the request
that is fine you can safely remove them
and now this is a perfect post request
going to login.php using http 1.1
again if you didn't know this if you
didn't remove that
still the request is working fine and
you can use it but i like to be a
professional
now we know that this request is working
so instead of using the right password
and username i'm just going to give a
invalid username
and a invalid password again let's send
it once more to confirm
it's working fine now we can send this
thing to intruder
so send to intruder you see the intruder
tab highlights
i'll go here and it tells me what are
you attacking i am attacking localhost
that's correct on port 80 that's correct
because i'm not using https if i'm using
https
then i have to put port 443 here or some
other port depending on the
configurations
but since i'm using http so i'll make
sure this is untick here
now let's go to positions and the great
thing about burp is
it automatically positions everything
you see
these things are marked in green and
they have been positioned automatically
that's the auto mode of burp suite you
see the auto here
however in certain cases you may want to
add something
like if i want to add a position myself
where i want to do a sql injection
i may want to go ahead and select this
and i'll say add here and now this is
also marked as a position
i can clear all of these by pressing the
clear button
and i can again just say auto to
automatically select the right positions
which perhaps we does very well there
are four modes
sniper battery ram pitch fork and
cluster bomb
all of them have different purposes
sniper for instead
will try two payloads right it's trying
payload number one here which will be my
sql injection code here
and then my code over here but
sniper will do that one by one so for
example
it will try mysql injection here and
keep
the password as bansa whatever we have
given
in the input in the request so it will
only change
one payload at a time then once that
works it will keep this as it is
and it will change the password which is
the payload two
so it will change payload one keep the
second as it is
then it will keep the first as it is and
change the payload to so it's one by one
that is what sniper is
again all of these four have different
purposes battery ram uses both of them
together so if i use battery ram
it will change both of the payloads at
the same time
you can study more about this on ports
bigger website
is irrelevant for this lesson i'll just
go with sniper
in payloads you can select the position
since sniper uses just one position
you can use one and there are single
list
and other stuff here one of them is
brute forcer
where you can specify a brute forcing
combination
we can specify a character list minimum
length and maximum length
but we are not brute forcing a password
right
technically we are but not through a
brute forcer we are doing it through sql
injections
so instead let's go with a simple list
and you can load a list of test cases
or you can add a list here now i already
have a list so i'll click on load
and then load my payloads and you see we
have certain payloads in this list
you can create your own list that's just
a txt file or you can just go ahead and
add something
like here i can just click on add and
that will add it to the list
but i'll just stick with my list which i
just loaded
now there are 10 payloads in my list and
since
sniper uses one payload at a time for
both of the positions there will be 20
requests
and 21 to be precise because it will
even generate a baseline request which
will be using both of the parameters
that we provided
so it will just go ahead and send this
request as it is
that will be the baseline request you
can go ahead and click on start attack
and it gives you the warning it's the
free version the community one
it will be slow that's fine we just have
21 requests
now you can see the first one is always
the baseline request there is no
position used it's like the blank
request
you see the one which we give
and then there are all the payloads that
it has tried for the position one it has
tried this
then for the position to let us try this
over here
but how do you define which one worked
and which one didn't
well you may go ahead and see what is
the difference in these
requests all of them are having the same
response code
i don't see any error or timeouts but
here in length you see all of the
lengths are different
you can go ahead and click on response
and render
and you can see what was the response of
the request
none of these worked
however if we see these four thousands
you see it has worked so now these four
thousand requests are all working
but there is much cleaner way to do that
i'll just close this
and instead there is fourth tab here
which is options
i'll click on this and options there are
many but you can set this
grep match option just clear all of
these
make sure this flag is ticked
and add something like welcome
press add and now it is set
the reason i have added welcome is i
want to flag all those requests
which have the word welcome
so basically when i start this attack
now
you will see it'll start flagging the
requests which have the word welcome
just like this one and this one and this
one
now once the attack is finished which
just happened
i can go ahead and filter it with the
flags
so all of these four requests are the
one which are resulting in a successful
sql injection
i can see if i give it a response and
render
and render this is the word which i just
filtered for
when there is successful login it says
welcome back so i just
flagged any response which has welcome
word in it
that is why we are getting these flags
and now you know
that these four payloads will work for
your sql injections
that is how you use semi-automated tools
to uplift the hard work
and do sql injections
using fully automated tools for sql
injections
well there are certain cases when you
have to test an application which has
thousands and thousands of pages even
semi-automated tools cannot work for you
in those cases you may want to run some
fully automated tools just like
sql map you can go to sqlmap.org
and download the zip file once you have
the file extract it to any location you
want
in my case i have extracted this file on
my c
drive directly
here you can see a folder sql map
and there are all the files which you
get in this
zip which you just downloaded now
just go ahead open the command prompt or
a terminal in case of unix
in the same folder
and now you can just type python
sqlmap dot py
since i am using python command make
sure
python is already installed in your
system if not
go on google download python and install
that you can even do that from microsoft
store
in case of windows so i assume you can
do that
let's press enter
and you will see it loads sql map and
then gives me an error
missing mandatory options d-u-l-m-r-g-c
and all the other stuff that's all fine
just click enter and now
instead of sql map just give it an
option called dash hh
which is extended help
as soon as you press that you will see a
lot a lot of options which you can use
in a skill map to do fully automated sql
injections
the first one which you need to
understand is of course
the url there are a lot of options right
there you go dash u dash url
to give a specific target
then the second which you need to
understand
a minimum one is the risk level
where you see the level level of
tests to perform one to five and default
is one
when you want to do complete testing you
would use the level five
not level one the reason of having these
levels is
that maybe we just want to test
something
in a low level and we have a low
bandwidth on our database
so if we use all the tests we may crash
the database
same thing applies to risk when you want
to keep the risk of crashing the
database corrupting the tables
and and even getting caught while doing
a pen test
you don't want to do all of that keep it
on one however you can increase it on
three
if it is a crystal ball test just like
we are doing right now
there are many other options you can
even choose the technique
which is dash test technique and you can
choose between all the techniques
like a boolean based injection error
based injection
union based injection etc etc
other options are also here you can
extract data
if you want using database
table column user to select the things
and dash does dbs dash dash tables
dash dash columns and dump to extract
the data
let me show you an example here in
practice
so i'll go ahead and use dash u
http localhost slash
login dot php
and i'll give it a risk rating of three
and level as 5.
let's press enter now you can see you
have not declared cookies
while server wants to set it on cookie
this one
so do you want to continue yes that's
fine we can take this cookie
nice testing sql injection ore based you
see
boolean based actions are being tested
first
then once it is done with boolean it
will start with some other
tests like from union based so it's
going to do all the testing for us
automatically
as testing is the mysql is less than
this more than this
using boolean and postgresql says
testing the version of the database
right now
it's going to take some time let's leave
it till then and you can see it is
asking us
it is recommended to perform only basic
union tests if there is not at least one
parameter one potential other technique
found
do you want to reduce the number of
requests well this is going to reduce
the number of tests which we are doing
by reducing the number of level and in
this case i'm going to allow this
because i don't want to wait for such a
long time when i know there is any skill
injection
in a real life situation you may not
want to allow this and reduce the number
of your tests
now you can see a skill map ends up with
an error
saying nothing is injectable it was not
able to find any skill injections
with our current setup that is fine it
happens
there are many things which you can do
to fix it you can provide
it with the fields to inject so if i
show you the help again
you will see there are certain fields
which you can inject by putting
dash dash data
so let me see where they are here you go
dash data you can tell it that go ahead
and inject it in this
specific field by selecting dash data
this can be complicated for some people
who do not know html css javascript
because you will have to find which
field are we injecting the data in
in our case we are injecting the data
in these fields username and password
but you need to know the name of these
fields so you may have to inspect the
element
and you may have to find that in this
html or
you may want to intercept the request
and find it there
an easy version will be just use burp
suite
go ahead and start a temporary project
open your proxy start your browser
go to localhost
go to login and here
go ahead and give it something like
sagar sagar1
i don't need the browser now i will go
to http history
or in the target and i'll take this
request
send it to repeater
and i'll just clean this request a
little bit because these characters may
cause problems
so this is login.php request which is
taking two parameters
this one and this one instead of these
parameters press a
asterisk sign
now once you add this ester is sign this
is called sql map payload marking
now i can just save this to a file
i'll save it in my c drive in my sql map
the same directory where i'm running it
i'll save it for example any name like
request
dot txt and this is save
i'll close the burp suite i don't need
it now
and if you go ahead and run this
this time
instead of giving it a url you can
specify the request file you created by
dash
r request.txt
and you can go ahead and give it the
levels and risk let's go with the
default this time
because that will be faster
and it'll say custom injection marker
found
do you want to process it of course
that's why we created it
and it says redirecting to this do you
want to do that
yes we want to use http localhost bird
at login.php yes that's what we are
testing
the result is a post request do you want
to resend the original post data in the
new location
yes we want to send the original data in
this new location
which is login.php
okay it looks like the backend database
is mysql
wow it just found that right do you want
to skip testing payloads for specific
other databases
of course we don't want to test others
because if it is mysql
then yes let's just test for mysql
for the remaining test do you want to
include all the tests for mysql
extending the level one and the risk one
well you can do that in this case i'm
skipping it to make sure
we complete this lecture on time
let's see if it gets us the result this
time
now you can see over here custom post
parameter number one
so the number one marker which we put in
the user name
it is testing that right now and it says
post parameter number one is vulnerable
you want to keep testing others
you know in the life situation you can
test it and the second parameter is also
vulnerable in our case
but i'm going to skip it right now
because i found a one parameter so
that's all good
now these were the payloads that it has
used for
number one you can see user name and
then a single quotes
and then select something something
something we are something
sub select something from sub select
count it's a long payload
i don't think i would be ever able to
write this kind of complex payload from
my hand
and that's where the automated s
conjections really stands out
you can copy this as it is and take it
and find whatever data you want
in the real website or you can use a
skill map to do that work for you as
well
so this time i'll say you know what find
me the databases
dbs it'll find me the databases this
time
and say do you want to use the marker
yes i want to use the marker
and we gotta redirect that's fine yes
use the data
and now it'll just give me the databases
because
it knows that the first parameter is
vulnerable
it has already saved all the data and
here are all the databases
i can find let's see i can select the
database sbba
and i can find the tables
again yes yes yes
and you see we got the tables and these
are the payloads that it is using
starting from here ending here again
super complex stuff
i cannot write that now let's select the
table
let's say login
and let's say you can find the columns
but i'll just dump it as it is
so yes yes yes
and here we go we just dumped the whole
table as it does instead of finding one
column at a time
item the whole table if you want to find
the columns also you could have done
that
by pushing dash dash
columns
and then it'll just you know go ahead
and find each column for you
okay invalid character c-o-l-u-m-n-s
there you go now it finds the columns
and you can select a column and dump
that so you know really depends like
dash
c and you know like id and dash dash
dump
so in this case it'll only dump the
column or you can just dump the whole
table by just
ignoring this column thing and just say
dump over here itself
so it really depends you know if the
table is too big you may want to do
column wise
and here this will only dump the first
column as i said
but again you can always dump the whole
table no need to dump
column wise if you know that the table
is
small so that is how you use
sql map to do automated sql injections
defending sql injections is not an easy
task that is the reason this old
technique
is still prevalent in the market there
are so many websites
which daily get attacked due to a skill
injection
there are many methods to do that most
of the security practitioners will go
with code sanitization
which will include things like input
validation parameterized queries
stored procedures escaping avoiding
administrative privileges
those kind of secure coding practices
since this is not a coding course i will
not cover
how all of these actually works i can
give you a reference
to ptsecurity.com and they have a really
good guide explaining
how to securely code all of these things
which i just mentioned
you can see input validation they talk
about it
and the code which you have to put and
how do you have to put that
parameterized queries the code and how
you have to put that
however i will tell you my specific
approach
which is also one of the best industry
practices
instead of just focusing on the code and
focusing on the development side
you should focus on a multi-layer
defense
now the multi-layer defense works in
minimum of three different layers
the first layer of course is the one
which you see right now which is the
code
all of these techniques you put that you
do secure recording
that is your multi-layer defense layer
one secure coding practices
layer two is including a web application
firewall this is a vaf which runs on
wordpress cms
you can scroll down and i'll show you
all the available attacks which you are
defending against
in my case sql injection is set on
enable mode
so this valve is going to stop any sql
injection attack
that occurs on my website let me show
you my logs
which will reveal a lot of ips who have
been attacking my site
every single second you can see there
are
number of ips and this is the current
date
and i believe it's like eight minutes
ago someone got blocked
10 minutes ago someone got blocked 10
minutes ago 12 minutes ago
14 minutes ago this happens when you
have a huge website
and actually a network of websites just
like mine
so all of these are being blocked due to
certain reasons
and the vaf is protecting that well
that's your second layer of defense
the third layer of defense is having a
vaf placed on the edge
which is normally the dns in this case i
use
cloudflare on cloudflare you can add a
new site by clicking on this button
and configuring the dns and in this
i will open my site
here i can go on firewall
and i can go and manage rules now again
this web application firewall is a paid
product
it's not available in the free version
but i'm still showing you because that's
how you have to do it in the real
industry
i can go ahead and see these rule sets
and you can see i have selected some of
them which applies on me
so because my website runs on php i have
applied this rule
and you can see over here all of these
rules are being protected against
then i have applied wordpress specific
configurations
which are all of these rules being
applied on my website similarly there
are flash rules
and there are other stuffs as well you
can see it goes on and on and on
this is how you protect a device in a
multi-layer defense
there are many more layers you can add
you can add an intrusion detection
system intrusion prevention system an
application delivery controller
a security orchestration automation
response system a managed monitor
automation response system
and much more depending upon how much
your organization is ready to spend
and what level of security you are
looking for let me show you an example
i'm going to go on my website
and go to the search and i will search
sagar
quotes or one equals one and comment
and let's see what happens here you go i
just got blocked by cloudflare which is
sitting on the edge side of my server
it doesn't even crosses this layer let's
say someone was able to bypass this
they will have to face word fence and if
they were able to bypass that
then my secure coding will stop the
attacks
so i may even survive an attack where my
code is vulnerable
but if i have the right security devices
placed then also majority of hackers
won't be able to exploit anything
and that is how you protect against sql
injection attacks
you